oh
what a summer an emotional roller
coaster i ran over a turtle in the
parking lot
but then i saved him by gluing his shell
back together
but i'm not that good at puzzles ah that
piece doesn't go there
so i patched him with stuff from around
the office
but i couldn't get the pieces to fit
right then
one day while i was reaching for the
glue
i crushed his shell again but i rebuilt
him even better that time but it turned
out the turtle was already dead
probably when i ran over him the
first time
well i need to give my cat up for
adoption
the one who uses the doorbell or the one
with the mexican hat or the one with the
rain galoshes or the one that you let go
around naked angela's cats are cute so
cute that you just want to eat them
but you can't eat cats
you can't eat cats kevin
no the one with the long hair and the
denim pants comstock
okay look he's such a special kitty
i just want to find him a good home
[Music]
he loves those pants
i'll take him
please after the turtle i am enormously
proud of what i did for that turtle
i can't keep doing this forever it's
been 20 seconds
call it
are you gonna answer that kel
all right thanks
dunder mifflin this is kevin
please hold while i transfer you
oscar your mom
charles is having kevin cover the phones
for a while
how do i say this diplomatically
i think kevin is doing exactly as well
as anyone might have expected someone
like him to perform in a position like
that
please hold
andy phone call nope stay there
kev i thought we nailed the whole
transfer thing earlier yeah i wrote it
on my hand but then i washed it it is
transfer extension and then transfer
again okay andy get ready transfer here
we go extension
transfer
ah oh man
it is one three four kev kevin come on
you are murdering the gnar dog this is
kevin please hold and i will transfer
you
you're bad at this too don't answer that
call just transfer the damn goal your
call is very important to us please
[Applause]
my maid died
well
have we all calmed down yeah yes sorry
about that
it was all my fault
let's all try to do better next time
kevin great to see you yeah thank you
for the food oh and also
you suck
i beg your pardon you are like a
terrible person
these guys care about you and you're
just
using them
again the food was very good
but an awesome party the best wedding
i've ever been to i got six numbers
one more would have been a complete
telephone number
this was epic
my kleenex shoes were a huge
conversation piece
but man
my dogs are barking
my feet were so sweaty i can't even
build a coal
so
you all want to know what i was in for
no
that's not cool
you don't have to tell them oh i really
don't mind it was a stupid mistake
yeah
i was working in finance and i got
involved in some insider training so i
spent a little time in the clink
that is awesome
i had martin explain to me three times
what he got arrested for because
it sounds an awful lot like what i do
here
every day
hello hello mr hamper i'm calling from
the identity staff department at capital
one we've detected some unusual activity
on your credit card
oh man do you think it was stolen
chris would you mind verifying your home
address
um yes
um
383 lyndon ave scranton pa and may i
have the last four digits of your social
security 6650
well mr halpert you're obviously not in
san juan puerto rico
wait a minute yes i am going to go ahead
and put a hold on your card no
that
i
i think that we should let the criminal
use the card a little longer
very funny sir we'll get a new card out
to you right away no have a nice day and
thank you
shoot
hey so this isn't matching up with this
and i'm not sure which one's right can
you just hunt down the original form yes
me do all right
hey kev what were you saying before
about the paperwork
we doing now
go stop worry
kevin do you feel okay me feel good
body's strong sleep big last night yeah
i think we should get him to the
hospital yeah all right kid why don't
you come with us no no no he's fine fine
he's always been like that no he hasn't
i mean he's gotten worse over the years
he's making a statement it's an ironic
comment on our expectations of him
a fun house image of our model of kevin
you keep think that
me mechanic not speak english but he
know what me mean when me say car no go
and we best friends so me think why
waste time say lot word when few words
do trick
kevin i
appreciate what you're trying to do bank
here we have a word code
the same way we have a dress code and
what we're talking about is
basically the speech equivalent
to just wearing underpants
sometimes words
you know need use
but need need for talk talk
but save time more success does it save
time though because we've been here for
about an hour no me fault
kevin
at most you're saving a microscopic
amount of time
many small time make big time
what are you gonna do with all this time
sea world
kevin you can't possibly save enough
time to see the world kevin are you
saying see the world or sea world sea
world
oceans fish
jump okay china no see right there
that's the problem with your method
because i still don't know if you're
saying see world or see the world and
it's taken a lot of time to explain it
fine
fine i'll talk normally
when me president
they see
they see
hi
i keep seeing this symbol in the
accounts from last year it's it's all
over the place i don't know what it
means that's the reason kevin got fired
it's his magic number he used to use it
to balance his accounts he used to call
it a cleveland he told dwight a mistake
plus cleveland gets you home by seven
he was home by 4 45 that day
uh i get it everybody knows about the
ultimatum yes i told everyone
hey
right back at you [ __ ]
hi everyone
hi
hi
uh look it's no secret hi
hello
i will quit
as god is my witness i will quit if this
is not fixed
some of us like the walk more than
others oh it's like hell
well gabe asked me if there were any
really cool lady gaga moves that he
could do for the catwalk
and so then i told
all right i told him that there was this
one cool move where she powers down like
a robot okay okay but i i i'm so sorry
that i didn't tell you first well
don't let it happen again you think that
i would let this happen again
no way jose
i'm
you gabe
at least once a year i like to bring in
some of my kevin's famous chili
the trick is to undercook the onions
everybody is going to get to know each
other in the pot
i'm serious about this stuff
i'm up the night before pressing garlic
and dicing whole tomatoes
i toast my own ancho chilies
it's a recipe passed down from malone's
for generations
it's probably the thing i do best
you